المملكه جدا غنيه في في الاثار والحضارات
اللي موجوده يعني عندك فقط في منطقه واحده
اللي نعرف عنها تقريبا سبع حضارات اذا مو
اكثر اللي الان نعرف عنا ففي علم الاثار
دائما في كثير تصير انها مع التنقيبات
يعثرون على حضارات ما قد سمعوا عنها من
قبل ذات عندك العصور الحجريه ما كان في
كتابه كلها رسومات فممكن نكتشف موقع اقدم
الاستيطاني الانسان هجره ممكن نلقى عظام
اقدم لان المواقع اللي من مليون سنه من
مليون سنه ما لقينا عظام الهيكل العظمي او
شيء للانسان فقط مستوطنات او ادوات فعندك
كمان الربع الخالي الربع الخلفي كثير من
الاثار عندك بحيرات كانت
الاستيطان جنبها ايش المتعه في التنقيب عن
الاثار انا تجربتك الشخصيه انت سبق قمتي
باعمال تنقيب
وين سويت ايش المتعب فيها وهل هي عمليه
صعبه هي صراحه اذا انت شخص توه هذا الشيء
عمليه زي ما انا دائما اقول كاني عبر
الزمن لانه انت تحفر يعني اتذكر مره موقف
كنا نحفر خاصه باخلص حفر عشان وارجع لسا
كان عندي محاضرات بالجامعه فالدكتور قال
اني اطلع برا المربع فجاه جاني دكتور خلاص
فطلعنا فقال ناظر المربع حقك ايش تشوفين
فاناظرت المربع وفعلا لقيت هنا فجاه هذا
الجهه الجهه في كانت سوداء وجيها في عندها
زي مطحنه وفي جهه عندها فتحه حقت الخيمه
قال طب الحين ايش تشوفين كنت هذا كان اكيد
المطبخ وهنا كانوا الخيمه يعني وين
يركبونها وهنا كانوا وين يطحنون قال
معناته بنخر نشوف ايش كانوا ياكلون فلازم
تطلع برا فبعدين استوعبت انه تصير تستوعب
انه اشرح القى الحين فيعطيك تصور الحياه
الانسان البساطه يعني احيانا تلقى حتى
الفخاره زي ما هي مو مكسوره ولا شيء
فالجميل بعلم الاثار انك تدخل بدون اي
تفكير يعني ما تدخل على تفكيرك انك بالفين
2023 لا تدخل عندك ما تعرف في اي زمن راح
تصادف فتعيش التجربه ايش ممكن تلقى ايش
الاشياء اللي راح تتوقع تلقاها واشياء
تفاجئك لانه دائما اروح ما نعرف اسال
الدكتور ايش ممكن نلقى اليوم يقول ما
تعرفون هذا الجميل انك ممكن تقعد اسبوع ما
تلقى شيء يعني اول فتره قعد اسبوعين ما
لقينا شيء بدي اطلع معبد وين هذا تل
السخنه بالاردن
وحفرنا في جرش كمان كان في تقنيه تجي
فيزيكس في الاجهزه التي ترسل اشارات وتعرف
اذا في تحتك فتقريبا بالاردن ترى في كل
الاردن حفرتي